well democrats are positioning
themselves for a major power grab in
congress that could clear the deck for
their radical agenda
president biden coming out in support of
the liberal push to weaken
the filibuster in the senate biden
changing his stance after massive
pushback
from the left wing of his party
i don't think you have to eliminate the
filibuster you have to do it what it
used to be when i first got to the
senate
and that is that a filibuster you had to
stand up and command the floor
so you're for that reform you're for
bringing back the talking filibuster i
am
that's what it was supposed to be just
put a hold on it that's it yeah
it almost is getting to the point where
democracy is having a hard time
functioning
senate republicans ripping biden and
warning democrats that they are playing
with fire mitch mcconnell saying any
potential rule change
would lead to a quote scorched earth
senate so
juan mitch mcconnell often times warns
democrats that they're going to regret
changing the rules he did this with
harry reid
and then he's always right when
republicans get back in power
and use the rules that democrats changed
to their
advantage do they risk doing that here
yeah i think that's exactly why my
prediction katie
the filibuster stays uh because i think
that you know there are
all kinds of options for republicans
uh and they especially large options if
republicans
you know take the senate back whether
it's 22 24 whenever
um you know but the you know the big
question for me
is no matter where you stand on the
filibuster
i think all of us have to ask answer
this question
do you really think that the united
states congress
is working for you and me and the
american people and i think the
overwhelming answer is
no and i think the filibuster is part of
that problem
nothing gets done nothing can get done
it's just too big
60 vote majority to really solve our
problems to deal with what
the congress was intended to do you know
help us help the american people be a
better country
i think that you know mcconnell talks
about well if the democrats take away
the filibuster it's going to be a
hundred car
pileup nothing's going to move on this
highway
uh senator mcconnell we've got a train
wreck right now
a train wreck in which nothing gets done
zero we don't deal with any major issue
in the congress at all to me this is
stunning and i you know for the first
for most of the history people would
maybe do
one filibuster a year and it would
simply slow down legislation it didn't
stop anything
but since 2010 and obama my gosh it's
been total it's been 80 filibusters
a year and it stops everything from
getting done it's not right katie
so dana president biden says that
democracy is having
a hard time functioning but isn't just
ridding
the senate of a minority position
against democracy considering those
people are also elected by the voters
yeah so you also hear some people say
that it's unconstitutional that's not
that's not the case it it is
allowed under the constitution uh to
juan's point
um the filibusters have been used a lot
who use them most recently
all the democrats one of the things they
filibustered was coveted relief
yes okay so and then you say that
nothing gets done i mean they got
something done under reconciliation so
there's that
um i think the democrats plan right now
is to pass so many bills in the house
and then send them over to the senate
and then complain
that mitch mcconnell won't allow
anything to go through while trying to
pressure senators mansion
and cinema from arizona west virginia
and arizona to try to get them to change
their mind
now also to one's point is there a
problem when
the minor the majority with such a
narrow margin says
nothing can get done well okay well
maybe you should try to persuade
60 senators i mean that is actually
something
that would be worthwhile that's what
could get 60 votes
in the senate why why don't we try a
little bit more on the persuasion side
of things
rather than trying to end um
and minority rights in the senate yeah
so
greg i would argue that the filibuster
helps with
not pushing through bad legislation the
whole point
is to make sure that something is good
and thoroughly debated and
representative of
everybody and it's supposed to slow
things down so things that
get through are actually decent
exactly it's uh it's like an imodium
tablet and what you're talking about is
what what dana said it's like
why don't you stop trying to create
these monster bills that satisfy the
most
woke-tastic members of your party and
actually try to create something that
people want
and be persuasive look when the dems are
in power right uh
they don't like the filibuster when that
when they're uh
uh when they're out of power they're pro
filibuster
so it's a position one holds and
reverses
based on where they are in terms of
power
if this position were in the kama sutra
it would be called reverse hypocrite
so i'm you know who i think is i hope i
didn't i don't make you blush
dana uh with that joke but you know what
i am going to
i'm going to um i'm going to repeat what
our airy fleischer said today which is
such a great idea
go ahead abolish it but make it go into
effect
in the next congress so the people
voting for it
may or may not get a benefit out of it
and see where that goes
my chan my belief is it probably won't
go anywhere
or you know kick it to the supreme court
they're not doing much
you know they could probably handle this
would we
this vote shouldn't be by people with
skin in the game is what i'm saying
yeah jessie i want to know from you
whether you think joe manchin and
kristen cinema will actually hold the
line
and and vote against eliminating the
filibuster uh
i don't have a lot of trust in joe
manchin but i think he'll hold the line
yeah i think i think he'll hold the line
you guys have said it all
i don't have much to add i think juan's
right i can't believe i'm saying that
but the filibuster's not going anywhere
i i the democrats are saying that
democracy is having a hard time
functioning no
democrats are having a hard time
functioning with checks and balances
the whole reason you have the senate is
to put a cap on mob rule in the house
it's a deliberative body that's trying
to forge consensus
and if you get rid of that you're going
to have the republicans control all
three branches
you get gun legislation abortion
legislation
you get immigration restrictions and
then the democrats come in the next
congress
tax cuts the next time the democrats
come in they spend the whole time
trashing that and then republicans come
back they trash
that it's just unstable and and if
you're a senator
do you really want to be a congressman
the whole reason you
got elected to the senate is because you
don't have to be in congress
that's the selling point that's true
true
it's like we'll play by your rules if
you want to that's just fine mcconnell
always warns
our